(pen scribbling on paper)
- You said that everyone knew each other
and then you knew the same people
when you went to high school.
- I knew some of the same people,
'cause like I transferred with them.
Oh my gosh guys,
I'm literally in private school.
- Your story is very shifty.
(upbeat music)
- [Moderator] We brought together
seven private school students.
- I'm a private school student.
- I am a private school student.
- [Moderator] Two of them
are public school students.
If the group discovers who the liars are,
they will split a cash price.
(upbeat music continues)
If the liars survive,
they win the entire price.
Who is the odd one out?
- What's everybody learning in school?
- I'm taking film, geometry,
Spanish, health and wellness, history,
English and conceptual physics.
- AP world, English honors,
Spanish honors, religion,
public ethics and morality.
- I'm in English honors,
history honors, science, honors,
Spanish honors as well,
and I take art advance.
- Math, Hebrew, history, art, science.
There's much.
I can't think of anymore
right off the bat.
- She couldn't remember one of the classes
that she attended,
which I thought was kind of odd to me
since you've been in a
class for half a year now.
Another thing I can't get off my mind.
I'm the only one in an actual uniform.
Like I have a question for you.
So what's with the uniform?
- I have a dress code on uniform.
We're only allowed to wear
like baby blue or light blue,
gray, Navy and white.
But we're only allowed
to wear white on Fridays.
- Yeah, so it's color coded, yeah.
- Yeah, we have--
- I only wear these on Thursdays
'cause we go to chapel.
- Ours is just khakis and a polo shirt.
- His uniform,
it didn't look unique to
like a private school.
- Once a month on Fridays,
we're allowed to wear jeans.
- That's what we do on Friday.
We wear spirit shirts or jeans.
- Why don't we go around
and say all our grades.
- I'm in seventh grade.
- I'm in eighth grade.
- Yeah, I'm a freshman.
- I'm a freshman.
- Eighth grade.
- Sixth grade.
- I'm in seventh grade.
(timer ticking)
- Yeah, already.
(bell rings)
That was fast.
(upbeat music)
- A lot of the classes that she named
were stuff that my
friends in public school
are currently taking.
(upbeat music continues)
- At least in my experience,
private schools don't really
have sixth grade in it.
It's usually seven to 12.
- A lot of other people here
are wearing a lot of like bland colors.
She's wearing a bright red shirt
and that kind of stood out to me.
- [Moderator] There's a tie.
(dramatic music)
The tie is between Halle and Audrey.
so each person has 20
seconds to state their case,
starting with Halle.
- I'm a private school student.
I go to Harvard Westlake.
I play volleyball.
I'm a Libera.
The season just ended.
I'm part of the BSU video
games club and the book club.
(bell rings)
- Okay, my name's Audrey.
I go to a private school.
I really like innovations.
I have a super small class,
10 kids including me.
I played school soccer.
I really like the science
lab and doing experiments.
(bell ring)
(upbeat music)
(buzzer sounds)
- Okay.
I'm actually really surprised
that I lost the tiebreaker.
I thought it was gonna be Halle.
- Why don't we just give
like a brief description
of what our school's like?
- I'll go first.
It's a decent size school.
We have at least 20 kids
in our class, if not less.
You know everybody there.
And it's a high school too.
It's a middle school and
it's an elementary school.
- She was very quick to volunteer,
which just felt like she
was trying to get the group
off her back.
- There's two campuses.
There's the lower and upper campus.
Right now, I'm on the lower campus.
In both campuses I'd say
there's about 1,500 people
and there's like 15 people in each class.
- Wait, wait, you said
1,500 people in each class?
- No, no, no, no.
In the whole...
In both campuses.
(all laughing together)
- I've been going to private
school my entire life.
In elementary school it was really small.
Everyone knew each other.
The teachers knew the students,
the teachers knew the parents.
They knew my entire family.
If something happens like in the morning,
by lunch, everyone knows about it.
I had a crush on this boy
and rumors were going around.
I was in fifth grade.
And they called my mom
and talked about it.
And my mom got so mad.
- I'm a K through 12 school.
So my school's pretty big.
There's lower school, middle school,
and upper school right now.
I'm obviously in the upper school.
We tend to stay away from the seniors.
They bully us a lot.
Our bathrooms are vandalized by them.
So we have to use the
upper school bathroom.
- Ours are too.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Moderator] Do you guys wanna
talk about safety in school?
Do you guys feel safe in school?
- When I was in public school,
I never felt unsafe in
regards to like physical harm,
but definitely in regards
to like verbal bullying,
that kind of thing.
Like I'm gay.
I wouldn't have felt
safe to come out there.
- Totally.
- At the public school,
there's a lot of bullying,
There's a lot of teasing.
I got teased for being gay in fifth grade
before I even knew I was gay.
I'm from the Bay Area.
So it's kind of a more progressive school.
It's a gifted education
program, four classes a day.
And then Fridays are like
a more development day
where you kind of do community building.
Run of the mill Bay area private school.
- My school's in Arizona, three buildings.
There's a cafeteria and gymnasium,
a seven to 12 building,
and then we have a K through six building.
I have honors English, science,
social studies and algebra.
Then my two electives are PE and theater.
- I'm a little suspicious of you.
- Yeah, same.
- Honors English, social studies.
Those are very, very typical
run of the mill public school classes,
especially social studies.
- After all that.
What's the best thing
about your private school?
And I'll go for first
because I used to be in a public school
from K through fifth grade
and then I transferred to St.
Margaret's Episcopal school.
The change in food, oh my gosh.
- So much better.
- The public schools,
the cheese falls off of the pizza.
- I went to public school
for like preschool,
and the one thing I remember
was like, the food was free.
So I was like, this is so cool.
But like now it's like, I have
to pay for it all the time,
but it's worth it.
- But Missy, just quick back to you.
You said earlier that you've
been in private school
your whole life?
- For pre schooling.
I don't count that, like, you know?
- Yeah.
- All I know is like the food was free,
but I didn't like it that much.
My school was like a K to 12,
but I transferred in eighth
grade to another high school.
I knew everyone,
so I wanted to like go
to a new private school
and I like it a lot more now.
- You said that everyone knew each other
and then you knew the same people
when you went to high school.
- I knew some of the same people
'cause like I transferred with them.
- Oh my gosh, guys, I'm
literally in private school.
- Your story is very shifty.
Can I have your full story?
I want it.
I want it beginning to end
because it's changed
like two different times.
- Okay.
For preschool, I went to
Chase Street Elementary.
Kindergarten, I transferred
to this other school.
I'm not gonna name it
'cause I don't want them
to get mad at me.
I transferred there.
I went there for nine years.
My sister went to the
same high school I do now
and she really enjoyed it.
So I was like,
I wanna transfer there for high school.
So I transferred there.
Now my entire family, we
love this school so much.
So yeah, I go there.
- I wish I liked my school.
(bell ringing)
(upbeat music)
- She couldn't keep her story straight,
kept getting flustered,
generally just suspicious.
(upbeat music continues)
(buzzer sounds)
- Wow.
- Bye.
I didn't think it was her.
- I think I definitely
got super defensive.
I started panicking, talking fast.
And I think that didn't help me.
- [Moderator] Raise your hand
if you think that the mole or the moles
are still in the box
and you would like to continue the game.
- I'm a little suspicious
of you 'cause you said--
- I'm suspicious of you too 'cause...
- We've got a war going on.
- Is this your school uniform?
- No, we don't have a school uniform.
We have like a dress code.
- You got the merch.
- Wait, so what is your dress code?
- I don't know how to describe it.
Like if put your fingertips.
You can't wear bikini straps.
Clothes have to like
touch fabric to fabric.
But for you I did have a question.
You said PE was your elective.
For me it's mandatory.
- For me, I have an elective as PE.
- PE is an elective, but
it's a required elective.
So you have to fill a slot for PE.
- Yeah, we have like
dance you can do though.
- There's a mandatory one.
You either have to choose
the Mozart performing arts
or you have to choose physical education.
So I just chose PE.
- Does everyone have a
creed for their school?
- A what?
- A creed.
Like--
- I've never heard of that.
- A school creed.
Like we are committed to honesty,
justice and learning.
We respect the dignity and
worth of all human being,
their thoughts, feelings
and individuality.
- We have...
We have a slogan.
- Yeah.
- We have a slogan too.
- Ours is, "Learn by
doing, learn by caring."
- Ours is just, "At Cooley Middle School
"We are kind safe and honest."
- We kind of just go by Bible verses,
like John 3 16.
We're very Christian school.
- Okay.
- We do a lot of chapel.
- That was gonna be the next question.
- Pray and stuff like that.
Yeah.
- Harvard Westlake, we have
like a bunch of things under it.
Things that you are like supposed
to do, kind of like rules.
- Could you tell us
more about your school?
'Cause I'm kinda a little.
- You never say--
(indistinct crosstalk)
Can you like elaborate on your story?
- Okay, I went to a
public elementary school
and then I switched in seventh grade.
- Did you say you were
in sixth grade earlier?
- Sorry?
No, no, no.
I never said anything about that.
Yeah, seventh grade I switched.
So we have two campuses.
We have the upper and lower campus.
There's about like 1,500 in each.
In the whole campus not in each.
Yeah.
And each class is about 15 people.
- When you say class, as in one bubble
moves from world history
to math, to science,
that kind of thing?
- Yeah, like that.
- And there are a hundred of those, okay?
- It's a really big campus.
- Okay.
- At our school assemblies,
I would like watch videos
and stuff like on YouTube
'cause they post literally
everything on YouTube
for like parents or whatever.
- How often were your
assemblies pre COVID?
- They're once a month.
- Once a month, okay.
- I'm really debating on
either you two right now.
- Yeah, same.
- I just wanna hear a
little bit more about--
- The way you described your school.
Like the school name,
the once a month assemblies,
putting everything on YouTube,
singing the star single banner.
- I think it's just a
general public school.
- That is the exact
schedule of the assemblies
that I had at every single public school.
- What's something
unique about your school
that differs it from a
normal public school?
- I already said it earlier.
You kind of had to choose
what you wanted to do.
Like physical education
or Mozart performing
arts for like the bass.
(bell rings)
(upbeat music)
(buzzer sounds)
- Bye.
(receding footsteps)
We'll miss you.
- Why would they vote for me?
I thought I had like some sort of like
trust system with them.
- I was really surprised because
everything I heard from Tom
sounded familiar from my school and stuff.
- [Moderator] Raise your hand
if you think that the
mole is still in the box
and you would like to continue the game.
- I thought we had gotten the
moles out; Audrey and Tom.
So I didn't wanna continue.
- So Halle, I am so sorry for saying this,
but thank God Olivia you
wanted the game to continue
because I would not feel
safe ending the game--
- Yeah, that's (indistinct)
- With you still here.
I just wanna ask,
what do you find that's
unique in your school,
and something that you haven't said.
- Since like the classes are smaller,
we get to like talk
with the teachers more.
- Do you call your teachers
by their first name?
- With some of them.
It depends with the relationship.
People aren't acting up as much
as when I went to public school.
So I feel like I just understand
the material a lot more.
- Yeah, I agree.
- But is the baseline education
better than what you
found in a public school?
- Well, first of all, I don't find myself
dazing off as much.
'Cause like it's just more interesting
what they're teaching about
and what we're learning.
In a public school, we learned
just about American history.
But now we're learning
about like Roman history,
Greek history.
We're learning about like world history.
- Like diversifies.
But then again, eighth grade is the year
that you would typically
learn about world history--
- But it's like...
- In public school.
- It's like, I feel like
we were just relearning
a lot of the stuff.
- I regretted going into round four
after Halle express her story
about being in a private school.
- So is this your day to day uniform?
- This is not my day to day uniform.
I just like being formal.
I just like wearing this.
I wear this on Thursday,
going to chapel, because it's
being respectful, I guess.
And the rest of the days
we wear a colored uniform.
We wear a polo shirt.
And pants, it's either khaki,
gray, crimson, Navy or plaid.
- Specific.
- Yeah.
I got it all.
- Do you have chapel?
- Oh, we have it every week.
Every Thursday.
- Same.
Every Wednesday for me.
- So you both attend religious--
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Middle school.
Mine is gifted education private school
and whatever you wanna do, go ahead.
- Our school's pretty diverse.
Yeah, that was the
question I was gonna ask.
Diversity.
Is it like, how would you
say, is there like a dominant.
- We have a director of
equity and inclusion.
- Yeah, we have what
they call the JEDI team,
justice, equity, diversity and inclusion.
I lead the gender sexuality alliance.
There's a feminism club,
Black student union.
- Are there any clubs
that you have joined?
Like, because I know
that they offer clubs,
students and teachers
- [Owen] Other than
video game and book club.
- I'm also part of the BSU.
- Okay, cool, cool.
- I'm sorry, wait.
What is the BSU club?
- Black Student Union.
- Oh, I'm so sorry.
- It's okay.
- Your application process
was just, you took a test?
- Yeah.
- So, okay.
- 40 grand to get in the school.
- Yeah.
- What about you guys?
They increased the price.
- Yeah.
- 20 grand.
- I have like tuition aid.
So yeah.
- Ours is 50,000, I believe.
(clock ticking)
- Yeah, oh my God.
(bell rings)
(upbeat music)
(buzzer sounds)
- Bye, Halle.
We love you.
- [Moderator] Raise your hand
if you think that the
mole is still in the box
and you would like to continue the game.
If the lights turn green,
that means you have voted
out the moles and you win.
If the lights turn red,
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
(dramatic music)
(upbeat music)
- Oh yeah.
- Go.
- Two moles.
- So good.
- Good job guys.
- Good job.
- [Moderator] Now, can the
moles please step forward,
in three, two, one.
(upbeat music continues)
(everyone yelling)
- I love how I was the
first one eliminated.
- It's okay, I thought it was her too.
- Yeah, I'm sorry about that.
Thank you.
I thought I was gonna get out first round.
Oh my God.
- 'Cause I know that
school and I was like,
I don't know if that's the uniform.
I told you so.
Like I knew it.
- Friend goes there.
- All of my friends go to private school.
(cross talking)
- You were convincing like--
- My answer sounded so weird though,
because my school was from
kindergarten to sixth grade.
I think they did really well.
And I was really surprised actually
that they were the moles.
I didn't really expect that.
So is your school a public
school or private school,
or did you just get it?
- I go to a public school.
I basically took on the
personality of my best friend.
So, she goes to a private school.
- You stole the soul of your best friend?
- [Halle] Yeah.
- Everyone is rich is
like a huge misconception
'cause I know a lot of students like
are on financial aid,
academic scholarships,
athletic scholarships.
- People always think
that private schoolers
are really bad and uncontrolled
and really conniving and mischievous.
I don't think that's them at all.
I think they're really outgoing
and passionate about what they say.
- I've always wanted to do this.
- I know.
- Yeah.
- Money things.
- Money.
(all laughing)
- The joys.
- Whoa!
- Capitalism.
(laughing)
- [Moderator] Can you
pick it all of that up?
Can you pick up all the money?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
Oh, that's a lot now, my bad.
Maybe if they told us we had
to pick it up I wouldn't do it.
- I still would've.